hey guys it is Tuesday and definitely
not dance birthday dude come on I don't
want people know what's my birth yeah no
I said it I said it wasn't your thing I
got you okay all right I'm Dan this is
Jess and this is games what news you
Jimmy said I'm getting your hands on an
SNES mini classic well after all of that
Walmart debacle and all the other
pre-order nonsense pre-orders are coming
to the u.s. in August Nintendo announced
that they will offer up an ample number
of systems following the supply issues
with last year's NES classic edition
Nintendo posted on their Facebook that
the SNES classic will be made available
for pre-order by various retailers late
this month
unfortunately no news on exactly when or
where so keep your eyes peeled
the SNES classic Edition comes packed
with 21 of the consoles best games as
well as starfox
2 which was never publicly released
here's the name you might not have heard
of in a while Mass Effect Andromeda has
been updated again update 1.10 is
primarily focused on the space rpgs
multiplayer mode said changes include
alterations to the Nullah dan rifle
whose explosion now gives damage when
cryo or incendiary ammo is used they
have also been changes to veteran ranks
and a number of bug fixes which will
rectify issues including a problem that
causes the screen to write out in red or
yellow flashes when using certain
weapons is rave about the term they use
in the patch notes no it was not
additionally the Dan shotgun should now
properly prime enemies you can check out
the full patch notes in our story on
games but if you're still arming an
airing over Andromeda there's a free
trial going on right now across ps4 Xbox
one and PC which lets you play for 10
hours if you want to know how to get
those head to our story on GameSpot or
you know just google it I don't know you
probably more tech-savvy than me anyway
since we're on the update train let's
keep it rolling with final fantasy 15
which is getting an update that adds
that Power Ranger armor magitek
accessory yes that is that after
delaying said exosuits because they
looked a whole lot like Power Ranger
costumes the armor has now arrived in
the game donning the exosuits makes the
party invincible for 30 minutes however
you can only use them once a day you
know otherwise it wouldn't be much of a
game anymore if you're wondering how
they change the suits to look less power
injury they now look like this damn
those are some tight suits July is
update also
the new cross-chain system to the game
as well as an additional quest to
undertake probably the biggest thing in
this update
apart from noctis's beefy thighs in that
suit is the return of the Mughal chocobo
carnival the limited time event
originally ran back in February and
features special carnival themed games
items and quests to experience that said
you will need the holiday park or
holiday pack plus DLC installed to
participate even if you don't have that
the fancy invincibility suits are still
free so that's good the chocobo carnival
will run until late September that's
everything from us for today so make
sure you're subscribed and you can see
us tomorrow Thursday and Friday and then
I'm not on the weekends though because
we go home shop it's because we've got
our electric personalities see you guys
might definitely not it
well after all of that Walmart debacle
and all the other pre-order nonsense
pre-orders are coming to the u.s. in
August